we are loving season three of
Nickelodeon's the loud house but no
animated series is perfect
check out these animation mistakes from
season three that you probably missed we
loved the loud house this animated
series from Nickelodeon is all about
life in a huge family
Lincoln loud it's the middle child and
only boy in a family of 11 kids all of
these sisters are hilarious and unique
and while they might not all get along
in the end they all love each other
season 3 debuted in January of 2018 and
has continued into the new year several
of these episodes had some animation
mistakes they were pretty sneaky so you
might have missed them tripped the very
first episode of season 3 is one of the
funniest loud house episodes ever it
also might be the episode with the most
mistakes in trips Lincoln loud tells
viewers that his family has finally
saved enough money to go on a real
vacation the whole family has been
working hard to make a family trip
happen they've all taken on different
jobs to contribute when they finally
have enough money they decide to go to
the weeping willow Resort and lodge but
the trip does not go according to plan
at all it's pretty much a disaster the
loud family piled into van Zilla and
hits the road unfortunately lone senior
decides to show off to a cherry farmer
he speeds up and crashes the van lonna
fixes the car but more and more things
go wrong then van Zilla ends up on a car
carrier and the lab family is stranded
they're stuck at a rest stop the family
joins an open-mic contest to try to get
money for bus fare they end up on a
prison bus then they steal a plane and
find van Zilla they finally end up at
weeping willow and enjoy their vacation
the first animation error happens when
they're trying to pass the cherry farmer
Lynn jr. tells her dad not to let the
cherry farmer pass them they're afraid
he's going to go slow the fact that the
cherry farmers truck is full of crates
each crate is overflowing with cherries
but in the very next glimpse the
cherries are gone the crate suddenly end
up totally empty other animation errors
happen
later on the airplane scenes have you
ever wondered how all the Louds fit in
that tiny biplane that doesn't seem safe
anyway they spot band Zilla on the back
of the card carrier some of the cars
disappear and at one point the logo on
the plane is suddenly missing
we know these aren't the biggest details
but how did the animators just miss
these roadie to nowhere loon aloud is
one of the most beloved characters on
the loud house she's the coolest of the
siblings and she's a talented rock
musician the fourth episode of season 3
is called roadie to nowhere chunk is
going with her to an audition for the
Royal Rumble but she finds out that
chunk used to be just like her next stop
rocket bull beep he was a rocker in high
school and he was sure he would become
famous but he didn't in fact he hasn't
done much with his life since Luna
auditions but then she totally freaks
out girl
we feel you planning your future can be
terrifying she tries to find a more
realistic career it doesn't go well at
all Luna is just made to be a rock star
she finds out that chunks still plays
music in a small band she goes to the
Royal Rumble and she performs with chunk
we're glad she decided to keep following
her dreams
the scene where Luna performs with chunk
has a couple of errors we've pointed out
the fact that she seems to keep playing
the guitar without hands in another
video but there's a whole other issue
Luna appears to totally lose a body part
at first her guitar strap is on her
shoulder but then her shoulder just
disappears her strap is awkwardly
dangling on the front of her chest
ouch that looks painful we guess it's
pretty hard to animate a rock out scene
a fridge too far the next type of
episode 3 is called a fridge too far
don't you hate it when you have some
delicious food waiting for you in the
fridge then someone else eats it without
your permission that probably happens a
lot in a family like the Louds but
Lincoln has had enough he rigs a booby
trap to keep his sisters from eating his
mac and cheese bites when LuAnn tries to
steal his food a watermelon falls on her
foot and breaks it
ouch Luanne loves a good prank so she
makes traps on her food too soon the
whole family is in on it everyone is
pranking each other and it's a disaster
they all get tired of getting hurt so
Lincoln and Lissa divide the fridge into
11 equal parts each one belongs to a
different sibling they all agree to not
touch anyone else's food compartment hey
wait a minute where will in senior and
Rita's food go their dad keeps putting
ingredients in the kids compartments
because there's no room but the kids
don't know whose food it is so they just
throw it away and then we find out that
their mom booby-trapped her own food too
waiting to try my food and all my
ingredients are gone
there are several errors in this episode
when Lincoln gets pranked he's suspended
from the ceiling by a rope at first the
Rope is down on his left foot
but when Luanne cuts him down the Rope
is on his right foot whoops
also when all the kids are putting food
into their own compartments the
animators messed up Lola is seen putting
her food in Lisa's compartment that
defeats the whole point of the
compartments Rita who writes the loud
parents don't end up in every episode
and we love it when they make an
appearance it's rare that they get a
whole episode to themselves in Rita her
rights
the episode is all about read aloud the
mom of all of those crazy kids
Rita drops off the younger kids at the
elementary school an illegally parked
van Zilla
she gets a ticket and the cop realizes
she owes over $2,000 in parking tickets
yikes
I can't possibly pay that but Rita has
another option she can do community
service she finds it relaxing once she's
done with her community service she
wants more so she gets more tickets uh
Rita you know you can do community
service without getting in trouble with
the Pops right it's called volunteering
for planned backfires and she ends up
doing a little time in jail when she
tells her family she just wanted a
little peace and relaxation they feel
bad she could have just told them so
they make a point to give their mom a
break every now and then two errors from
this episode happened at the high school
when Rita drops off Lenny LuAnn and Luna
at school Luna is in two places at once
she's seen outside of the band while
also being inside of the van that's a
huge mistake
also Lauri is a student at the high
school but she's nowhere to be seen in
any of the high school scenes teachers
union sometimes it's hard to imagine
that your teachers have lives outside of
school but there are regular people with
families and interests in Teachers Union
Lincoln and Clyde gets way too involved
in their teachers lives their gym
teacher coach pukowski is really hard on
them but then they notice that their
coach has a huge crush on another
teacher named mrs. Johnson class
dismissed
you are Getti the boys think their coach
will be way easier if he gets with mrs.
Johnson they ask Lori for advice on
impressing someone she taught them to
find out about their interests they
think that their coach is really
interesting he's got a medical book and
lots of photos next to World Monuments
so they tell mrs. Johnson what a cool
guy he is but they were totally wrong
the medical book is because coach has a
foot infection you look gross and the
photos were from a local mini golf
course mrs. Johnson is disappointed and
the date goes terribly coach is so mad
at the boys for interfering in his
personal life he chases them through an
obstacle course and hits his head then
he starts crushing on the school nurse
mrs. Johnson is mad about the date and
gives the class a pop quiz but then
Lincoln and Clyde realize she's in love
with the janitor we don't think they
learned their lesson about matchmaking
is one of those episodes that take place
almost entirely at school there are ton
of details at school it's easy to make a
mistake when animating these scenes in
one scene Lincoln and Clyde have their
backpacks on when they entered the gym
but then their backpacks disappear it's
not like they went into a locker room to
put them away they just vanished
where did they go the animators just
totally forgot about the backpacks
really loud music the end of 2018
brought a couple of full-length loud
house episodes we love these because
they usually have an awesome musical
number or two in really loud music Luna
is writing a song to submit to the
America's neck tip maker contest the
most popular songs will win a record
deal we know that Luna is an awesome
musician but she has a tendency to doubt
herself she starts wondering if her
songs are really good enough she wants a
song to resonate with everyone
Luna starts hearing songs everywhere she
hears Alana seeing a song about fixing
toilets
Lola sings a song about her beauty and
Lisa rapped about the periodic tables
[Music]
but they swear they weren't singing what
is going on with Lunas mind she's
hallucinating because she's so stressed
she keeps hearing the rest of her
sibling singing every one of her
siblings has a song about something that
is totally them like Louann sings about
comedy it gets weird and Luna thinks
she's going crazy
Luna comes up with a new song to submit
and enters the contest the contest hosts
tries to change Luna into someone she's
not but she refuses to perform as this
Lulu that they've created worldwide fame
is never worth giving up who you are we
love the message and we love all of the
songs the animation error in this
episode is pretty subtle you have to
really be paying attention to see it
when Louann sings her song about comedy
the animation styles change it's all
surreal with lots of bright colors her
unicycle is orange there's a giant
jack-in-the-box with louann's head it's
honestly all a little creepy but when
the song ends and the world goes back to
normal the animators forget one thing
louann's unicycle still looks like it
did in the weird musical number the
loudest Thanksgiving
last error is from the 39th episode of
season 3 the loudest Thanksgiving was
the last episode to air before the
winter break it's also one of the only
six full length episodes of the loud
house it's a Thanksgiving episode
obviously it's also when the loud and
Casagrande families meet for the first
time Laurie and Bobby are on the phone
and they're telling each other all about
their Thanksgiving traditions they're
getting pretty serious so they think
they should spend a holiday together
Lincoln and Hector think that if their
older siblings visit each other the
holiday will never be the same again
they get their whole families involved
in making sure Laurie and Bobby stay
home for Thanksgiving so loud and Casa
Grande families go out of their way to
make the teens feel loved
then Bobby suggests that both families
get together on Thanksgiving that leads
to an intense competition each family
wants to be the best at hosting it's
hilarious and it ends in a food fight
but Lori and Bobby were totally over it
they slip away from all the craziness
but they all decide that no one wants to
be alone on Thanksgiving they all
celebrate at flips restaurant it will
get you right in the holiday feels
I'm sorry boo boo bear I know you were
looking forward to having a real
Thanksgiving this year
there are several errors in this episode
the loud siblings Heights usually match
up with their ages that way it's easier
to see who's older but in one scene Luna
is magically taller than Lennie Lennie
is a lot older and taller so that is a
big mistake on the animators part it's
so obvious EPP lips restaurant
CJ Casas Grandes arm disappears at one
point and during this song baby lillies
eyebrows are just gone she had eyebrows
in every other scene where did they go
what other animation mistakes have you
noticed in season 3 of the loud house
did you notice these mistakes when you
watch the episodes let us know in the
comments section below there may be
mistakes in the loud house but clicking
that subscribe button definitely won't
be a mistake thanks for watching and see
you next time on the things
[Music]
[Music]